I'm not a historian but I know that a
lot of the devaluation of the teaching
profession has to do with the fact that
you know not so long ago it was really a
profession that was only open to women
for example and so culturally the status
of the profession was not what it should
be as the workforce opened up to women I
think what happened is teaching became
instead of something that very talented
women who couldn't get other jobs
because of the constraints and the
culture God now it was open to anybody
and it didn't pay very well and that
talent sucked to a certain extent
drained from the profession potentially
this is just a theory I really have no
idea and what you're left with is
pockets of greatness so you have great
teachers throughout the country
phenomenal teachers but ultimately
they're the exception not the rule and
that's because we don't culturally value
teachers people make the mistake of
thinking that the salary that we're
offering is somehow designed to make a
mediocre teacher better completely wrong
if you pay somebody more it's not going
to make them a better teacher that's
completely missing the point of the
project the point of the project is just
change the perception of who should
become a teacher it's to change the sort
of lip-service mode of o teachers we
really value you to something concrete
in this culture money is a signifier of
value and so ultimately the goal is to
attract more talent into the into the
profession right now we draw from the
bottom third of college graduates to
make up our teaching force and that's
you know that's unfortunate the goal
should be to draw from the top third of
college graduates to to make up our
teaching force I think actually teaching
is one of those professions where there
are many people who secretly want to do
it and in
enjoy it when they're up there but don't
really view it as feasible they can't
support a family it's not really
realistic to achieve other goals that
they may have so I think teaching has a
built-in advantage over some other
professions we're four and I'm not not
to pick on lawyers but you know I think
there are a lot of people who love the
law but there are a lot of people who go
into the law just because it is it pays
the bills and it's a relatively
lucrative and respected profession I
mean that sense I think teaching
actually has a great advantage over
other professions the the problem is
that right now it's not realistic for a
lot of people who are talented to go
into it or they don't view it as
realistic and you know one of the
interesting things about Teach for
America is a lot of people who start the
program think oh I'll just do this for a
few years but then they fall completely
madly in love with it and stay on for
the rest of their career so that I think
is less likely to happen in some other
professions but teaching has a certain
magic to it that really gives it a lot
of advantages
we hired who we think are eighth grade
teachers we'll find out but they have a
very extensive track record for the most
part
several of the teachers have over 30
years of experience the teacher you know
the youngest teacher we hired still has
seven years of experience in the
classroom so one thing is we're not
hiring sort of first-year teachers
because not that first year teachers
can't be great but but the learning
curve is you know is is tremendous in
that first year so we're hiring veteran
teachers we're hiring teachers who you
know we actually visited their
classrooms everybody who made the final
round we went and saw them and so we're
hiring teachers who in their classroom
developed a certain relationship that
was apparent to an outsider with their
students teachers who are thoughtful
practitioners who are reflective about
what they do in the classroom who can
talk about what they do in the classroom
in an in a reflective way in a critical
way they can't they really think about
all of the decisions that they make
we're talking about teachers who showed
that they could really engage students
capture that enthusiasm which is
particularly important I think for
middle school kids and also teachers who
are adapted creating structures for kids
middle school kids again in particular
need structure and they need a teacher
who can manage a classroom through
routines through a variety of modalities
but those were some of the things that
we looked for plus of course we were
looking for teachers who were passionate
about their subject and who could bring
that passion and that extensive
knowledge to their students I actually
don't think so I would make the case
that one of the things about the school
that's very important is we do this on
the public dollar we are a public
charter school in New York City we
actually get less money than a
traditional public school in New York
City and yet we are able to pay teachers
one hundred twenty-five thousand dollars
a year plus a potential bonus based on
school-wide performance without fun
raising for that salary the only thing
we fundraise for is our facility and
that's because we don't get a free
public facility like every other school
gets but every other cost is absorbed or
is paid for by our public dollars that
we receive we have simply reallocated
those dollars and said you know what
really we need to be investing in the
most important part of the educational
experience for students and that's their
teachers we need to invest in what we
call teacher equity hence the name the
equity project and yes we are going to
sacrifice some other things to do so
we're not going to have tiny classes and
we have 30 kids in a class that's not
higher than I experienced as a teacher
in fact it's a little bit lower but it's
certainly not small we are going to do
without a lot of the other personnel in
the building that typically would be in
a school so we're gonna do a lot of
things to make sacrifices in order to be
able to invest in what we think is more
cost-effective in the long run which is
investing in the teachers